[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy
conversaremos con el doctor carlos
alberto pérez asesor científico de
francés 24 para dimensionar la gravedad
de la situación en haití tras el
terremoto que deja casi 2000 muertos y
el paso de la tormenta grace tragedias
que paralizaron la vacunación contra el
commit 19 de doctor gracias por estar
aquí con france 24 la organización
panamericana de la salud advierte que
múltiples desastres que han golpeado a
haití tiene paralizado el proceso de
esta vacunación contra la pandemia que
deben priorizar las autoridades médicas
en estas circunstancias tan complejas
como las que están viviendo
si realmente la situación de haití
requiere un apoyo multilateral y de
también desde varios aspectos el primero
infraestructura el segundo de insumos el
tercero del capital humano y el cuarto
el económico esta crisis ha llevado a un
retraso en la vacunación que de por sí
ya era tardía y además de eso las
grandes conglomeraciones que estamos
viendo en situaciones de hacinamiento
pues en caso de que haya una
diseminación viral pues va a ser mucho
más efectiva entonces el apoyo que se
requiere en esta situación es un apoyo
multifactorial en este momento ahora la
ope s dice que además se requiere mayor
ayuda internacional que el que ayuda a
prima más el doctor la humanitaria a la
logística o de las vacunas para la
pandemia
creo que cualquier ayuda en este momento
pues es insuficiente por la situación
que vive pero sin duda en lo primero es
capital humano e infraestructura
porque en este momento los edificios
dónde están los hospitales están
colapsados y hay muy poco capital humano
así que no hay insumos hay que priorizar
la infraestructura del capital humano
para hacer la atención como se hace en
el manejo de estas situaciones y después
de eso sí complementar con ayudas
económicas y otro tipo realmente la
situación necesita la solidaridad de los
demás no solamente contemplar lo que
está pasando sino realmente asociarnos
para poder ayudar a este grupo de
personas que lo necesitan y que
realmente han pasado en estos meses por
unos dramas inconcebibles en un
escenario como ese donde hay pandemia
sin vacunación con infraestructura
totalmente dañada y colapsada además que
se puede esperar en un escenario tan
caótico los sobrevivientes están
expuestos a virus bacterias infecciones
podrían deportar ellos la dosis de la
vacuna
raúl van a venir más problemas y créanme
que el problema menos va a ser el código
porque los problemas que trae el
hacinamiento la falta de insumos pues
son problemas sanitarios muy grandes que
se acompañan por ejemplo brotes de
enfermedad gastrointestinal que es el
brote de enfermedades de otras
enfermedades respiratorias y además de
eso pues la lamentable pues por la falta
de alimento que puedan suceder es decir
que estamos aporta desde una gran crisis
y por eso la intervención no tiene que
ser solamente con ayudas parciales o
sino tiene que ser una ayuda
multilateral
coordinada que prioricen en los aspectos
de infraestructura insumos capital
humano y capital económico pero sobre
todo la presencia de personas para que
podamos ayudar más y es necesario que
nos organicemos hoy con el grupo con la
gente de haití y no solamente lamentemos
lo que está sucediendo doctor que
podemos esperar en un futuro cercano
para los haitianos que necesitan fue el
último país de la región iniciar además
la campaña de vacunación viene precedido
por una serie de crisis como la que
estamos hablando incluyendo el terremoto
de hace 11 años del que aún no se
recupera es la nación más pobre de
nuestra región
sí yo creo que toda la solidaridad que
nosotros podemos brindar tiene que ser
realmente patente en el momento y
recordemos que si solamente un grupo
humano no se ha vacunado la inmunidad
colectiva tan pregonada no se va a
lograr y eso involucra no solamente que
los países ricos tengan vacunas sino que
todo el planeta y todos estemos
inmunizados hoy la gente de haití que y
para todas las personas de centroamérica
es importante que reforcemos la
vacunación en ese grupo de población
porque si no se pueden desarrollar
fenómenos como nuevas variantes que
pueden suceder en este tipo de
aglomeraciones y no se pueden descartar
y que pudieran terminar haciendo un
colapso o una nueva generación de
variantes que pueda afectar la región
por eso la solidaridad debe ser tan
importante en estos momentos complicada
y también triste lo que estaba
ocurriendo en haití doctor gracias por
su tiempo por estar nuevamente con
nosotros en france 24 ustedes a mí
gracias continúen con nosotros hay mucho
más para ver aquí en nuestro canal
[Música]